Let me break it down.
Jay High School,
they don't come through their door and
be good cop.
Bad Cop.
Don't fall for that.
All right.
In Hollywood,
everything important in an interrogation
is seen or heard.
The cops grimace allowed yelling,
treating a suspect hostile.
The light that's way too bright,
but in a real interrogation,
it's flipped around.
Everything important is unseen,
unheard on the surface.
Real interrogations look boring.
The cop is nice to you.
They give you a drink,
they dressed in plain clothes.
It's almost disarming,
especially if this is more of what you
were expecting,
but that's the point.
Under the boring disarming surface of an
interrogation,
you find a whole host of psychological
traps and mental tricks that are
designed to make you confess.
It starts from the moment you walk in.
Every inch of an interrogation room has
been designed to make you feel isolated
and powerless.
The room is small,
cramped.
The walls are blank and there are no
windows.
You'll be placed in an uncomfortable
straight back off in metal chair while
the cops chair,
we'll be able to roll.
This becomes important later on.
The next move is a hurdle that cops have
to get over.
When you go to jail,
a cop is legally required to tell you
you have the right to shut up.
This actually turns out to be the only
great advice you're going to get.
Talking to cops is always a bad move and
for the cop,
what this means is that their first
priority is making you ignore this
advice and go against everything you've
ever heard.
They have to convince you to play the
game with them.
The first questions are deliberately not
about the investigation.
They want to appear trustworthy so that
you'll talk to them about the case.
41 point mama stay downtown.
I don't think I've tried that one yet.
I'm a big coffee.
I don't know if you're a coffee guy
right in front of us,
so no,
I appreciate that.
All right,
go ahead.
There's a plane going up.
You get hungry or anything else,
just let me know.
Okay.
How come you get more than one bill
name?
You know,
my uncles and my grandfather,
I got to three middle name and that's
really because my parents thought I was
gonna be an only child.
Amy,
after everybody.
So I get named after your grandfather
and two uncles,
so I know what you're,
I know what you're going through there.
Cause my initials,
I get teased about.
The other goal behind these innocent
questions is to establish a behavioral
baseline.
They want to see how you act when you're
telling the truth.
Finally,
when they're ready,
they'll ask you something like this.
Well let's,
let's do this.
You sound like you will.
You won't talk to me.
Okay?
I want to hear what you have to say.
But before Ashley Quish,
she got to know your rights.
Okay?
You have the right to remain silent.
Uh,
what this says here is that I've read
you your rights.
Do you understand them?
Once you're talking,
they'll first get a statement about what
happened after hearing it.
If the cop thinks you might have done
it.
If the facts aren't lining up or if
you're acting shady,
they may move to the accusation phase
and the accusation phase.
They will confidently accuse you of the
crime and the cop will say,
in no uncertain terms,
you did it.
We know you did it and we've got
evidence for it.
Your vehicle drove up the side of
Jessica Lewis House,
your boots walked to the back of Jessica
Lloyd's House on the evening of the 28th
and 29th of January.
You and I both know you were at Jessica
Lloyd toughs and I need to know why,
but here's the catch.
They'll claim they have evidence for
your guilt even when they don't.
This nosy neighbor or whatever we're
going to call on him has monitored and
I'm not going to tell you how.
Okay,
just think about it.
With today's technology monitored,
what was going on in front of this
residence that they were calling to
complain about until police arrive and I
can prove it.
I can go in front of the judge and say,
hey look bro,
we want to fucking do you want us to
play this video?
You want us to show you the fingerprint
results?
You want us to show you the gre test on
on this gentleman,
I did not have a firearm in mine hand.
The goal here is to make you think that
you're already caught.
They already have you.
Why bother resisting and lying about it
when they already know you did it?
Just confess.
So it's,
it's,
it's a it.
It's one of the easiest investigations
I've had.
It's fucking there and you can't lie
about that,
bro.
You can't tell us how you then fucking
fire that fourth shot anymore.
You can't tell us.
We can prove otherwise
during this phase of the interrogation,
the interrogator doesn't want you to
deny the crime even though you'll want
to vocalize denials,
reinforces your position.
So Cox make an interesting move.
They try to not let you vocalize Denalis
in the first place.
If possible,
they'll often interrupt you or not.
Stop talking to allow brakes to let you
speak up.
Instead,
they'll keep the pressure on by
reinforcing the idea that they a hundred
percent already have you caught.
I'm giving you an opportunity to listen
to me.
Listen to me,
listen to,
I did not have a firearm in mind.
We can prove that we're beyond that
point,
buddy.
We'll be on that man.
No,
they did not do what you think I did.
I know you did.
Were passed,
passed.
You know it.
They know it.
Let's just drop the charade.
The next phase is themed development.
After accusing someone,
the cops will try to provide themes to
offer moral or psychological
justifications for the crime.
Nobody's going to confess if they think
it makes them look bad or their
dignities at stake.
So the cops want to give you a way to
lose without losing face.
This will never be used in your favor.
When the confession goes to trial,
of course,
these are simply mind games that are
used to get the confession.
We sort of believe that it could have
been a fucking accident.
It could have been accidental discharge.
Okay.
But when you don't,
when you're completely denying it,
and then I got to think another way,
Bro,
I don't believe you're a cold blooded
killer.
No,
I don't believe that at all.
Nothing's suggested it to me.
I think you're a smart guy,
and I think you got involved in a
situation that you probably shouldn't
have.
There's a difference between you going
in and saying,
I'm gonna kill somebody and you're going
in.
I'm trying to help somebody,
and then shit goes bad.
They're just waiting different things as
we're talking about.
What other options?
I don't think you want the cold blooded
psychopaths function.
I might be wrong because I don't get me
wrong.
I've met guys who actually kind of
enjoyed the notoriety,
got off on it.
I don't see that.
If I saw that you have when he'd be back
in,
you're talking to you quite frankly,
but maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe you got me fooled.
I don't know.
This is where most people start to
break.
Most people often go into a passive mood
when they're about to confess,
looking beat down and acting quiet.
This is the first time that you'll
seriously start considering confession.
There's even a physical tell called the
surrender position that cops look for to
know when you're about to confess.
It looks like this.
When the cop sees this,
he will continue to reiterate all the
themes that have been developed so far.
We know you did it.
We have evidence and good guys come
clean.
In addition to deploying psychological
measures,
the cup full also deploy physical ones.
Remember that the cops chair can roll
and during this time he will often move
closer.
In order to ramp up the tension in the
room,
you will feel trapped like there's
nowhere to go and meanwhile a physically
intimidated cop is telling you that you
have to confess.
You must confess.
Finally,
there's a moment when the tension that
has been building up for hours finally
breaks.
You can almost see it
minimizing sort of way that'd be do
that.
Wow.
You start out by telling the truth.
Okay,
okay,
where is she man?
And once the cop gets their confession,
it's all over your chance of being let
off.
Go to almost zero.
Your plea deals.
Get a lot worse and you have gained
absolutely nothing from the exchange
except for the knowledge of just how
good cops are at beating you in the
interrogation room.
I just think I'd look guilty if I hired
a lawyer.
Actually,
it's getting arrested that makes people
look guilty.
Even the innocent ones,
an innocent people get arrested every
day and they find themselves in a little
room with a detective who acts like he's
their best friend.
Talked to me,
he says,
help me clear this thing up,
but you don't need a lawyer.
Only guilty people need lawyers and
boom,
hey,
that's when it all goes south.
It's time to come clean.
Are you following me on these platforms?
We have communities on reddit and
discord and the bigger they grow,
the more fun they are.
Also,
I share a more personal side of my on
twitter and Instagram,
so follow if you're into that kind of
stuff.
Finally,
thank you to my patrons,
guys,
if you're not a patron,
please.
It helps my life so much to be making a
little bit of money from this channel.
I don't need to make a lot,
but every little bit counts so much.
So thank you guys.
Everyone who is supporting me,
music producers are as always linked
here and below.
And I will see you guys next time.
Got Conviction
of your conviction,
man.
It's simple addition and the dentis with
has gone to put you in prison.
So give us a sentence talking about Yo
contrition.
It's just a simple admission that may
help yo condition and that's the story
of how they get you.
Here's one final admonition.
Don't talk without a lawyer.